October is a month for colder weather  Halloween parties and more free games  from Sony I'm Tony this is a game spot  news update and this is your PlayStation  Plus October lineup keeping with the  Halloween themed ps4 owners are getting  the Resident Evil One remake they'll  also get their hands on platinum games  transformers devastation ps3 is getting  the ATV stunt game mad riders and  tropical God game from dust and if you  play on PS Vita you're getting the MV  hit actual sunlight and the visual novel  code realized guardian of rebirth any of  those sound good to you the new lineup  will be available on tuesday october  third until then you can grab  September's free games like Lords of the  Fallen and journey note that this is  also the first set of games released  under PS pluses new price and to keep up  with all the PlayStation news you're  already in the right place